here's a New York Post
headline Jennifer Love hwit slams being
sexualized in her 20s quote I felt
watched Jennifer Love hwit doesn't love
people who are still obsessing over her
younger self the 44-year-old was surely
The It Girl in Hollywood throughout the
90s and 2000s starring a career- making
hits such as Party of Five Heartbreakers
Can't Hardly Wait and I Know What You
Did Last Summer huitt is over trolls who
keep comparing how she looks now to how
her body looked in her early 20s
she was a looker The Client List star
said about her physique back in the day
while chatting on a recent podcast
episode huitt said but also that 23 and
25-year-old wasn't in her body I felt
watched I felt like I had to be
everything for everybody all the time I
was called sexy before I ever knew what
being sexy was I was 17 years old on the
cover of Maxim and I had no idea why in
2002 she recalled being told to be
sexier on the set of her romcom
Heartbreakers I know that I'm supposed
to be this thing for people but I don't
know what that
means that girl was so insecure and so
confused and trying her best but this
girl who may not look that way I like
who I am I feel good I'm fine okay
so first of all I have to say that I I
can relate um in a certain way because I
also feel watched when I'm on camera
even right now I get this strange kind
of eerie feeling that people are
watching I can't explain it I can't put
my finger on it maybe I'm
paranoid you know when I'm when I'm in
front of a camera I feel
watched It's almost like she was in a
business and I'm in a business where the
whole business is to be
watched It's almost like we're paid
generously to do these jobs of being
watched I don't know as for the rest of
it you know we see a lot of that of this
kind of thing these days you got these
actresses um it seems like every month
there's another one another actress it
was popular in the 90s or two early
2000s or before that now in their 40s
and 50s and 60s turning around and
claiming that they feel violated because
they were quote unquote sexualized when
they were in their
20s like they're they're going back and
complaining about everything that made
them a star all the things they
willingly participated in the
opportunities that they didn't just
willingly take but like kicked and
clawed and killed and did whatever else
to achieve and now they want to be
victims and you know it gets a little
bit tiresome I have to say now there is
an element often times with these sorts
of things there there's a there's a
valid element to it like she says that
she was a 17 years old on the cover of
Maxim well that's not right there should
be there should be 17 yearolds on the
cover of Maxim but then she's talking
about being a full-grown adult being
like 23 and
25 and complaining about the fact that
people appreciated her good looks and
it's it's kind of ridiculous and it does
have the feeling of someone who's maybe
a little bit bitter about the fact that
they've lost some of those looks I guess
and they've lost some of their their
youth now Jennifer Love hwit still a
very attractive woman women in their 40s
can be very attractive
obviously so I'm not the one saying that
that women can't be attractive after
their 20s I don't think anyone is saying
that well almost no one is saying that
but
um but this this it's like it's it's
another recognizable pattern that we see
here
Christmas is coming and while you're out
shopping for your kids family and
friends don't forget to shop for your
pets too give your dog the gift of a
healthier and happier life with rough
greens naturopathic Dr Dennis black the
founder of rough greens is focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America before I started feeding my dog
rough greens I had no idea that dog food
is dead food it contains very little
nutritional value think about it
nutrition isn't Brown it's green let
rough greens bring your dogs food back
to life rough greens is a supplement
that contains all the necessary vitamins
minerals probiotics Omega oils digestive
enzymes and antioxidants that your dog
needs you don't have to go out and buy
new dog food you just sprinkle rough
Greens on their food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves bad breath boosts energy levels
and so much more we are what we eat and
that goes for dogs too Dr Dennis black
is so confident Ru greens will improve
your dog's health he's offering my
listeners a free jumpstart trial bag so
your dog can try it get a free jump
start child bag delivered straight
through your door in just a few business
days go to Ru greens.com or call 844
ru700 that's rfffg greens.com or call
844 ru700 today and also you know
there's she says that she was being
sexualized in her
20s and kind of it's like this whole
idea
of when this we use this term of someone
being sexualized you she she was
self-consciously marketing herself as a
sex symbol in her
20s and I think that shows how we've
really started to use this word
sexualized in a way that removes all
meaning from the
term now there are ways that you can use
the word where it means something like
if you're talking about a child being
sexualized which is something that
happens a lot in our culture and it's
evil and terrible and the people who do
it should go to jail so that's one thing
but what does it mean for an adult woman
in her 20s to be quote unquote
sexualized what does that mean
exactly now I think usually it's used
like interchangeably
with objectified and so they say
sexualized and really what they mean is
kind of like objectified and again that
is something that does happen women who
are prostitutes as we just
saw are being objectified and
objectifying themselves if you're in
pornography you are being objectified
and you're objectifying
yourself and what does that mean it
means that you are you are being treated
like an object like not even a person
you are an object to be used for someone
else's sexual gratification and nothing
else and so if you are a quotequote sex
worker that's the gig that's what you're
doing and yes you are objectified it's
one of the things that makes it horrible
and
dehumanizing pornography again you are
nothing more than than a masturbatory
aid for whoever is watching it you're
not even a person you're just an object
as far as they're
concerned um but often these days so
there is in that cont
text we should be able to agree that
that's
objectification I suppose you could call
it sexualization too and it's a bad
thing well we should be able to agree on
that of course it gets very confused
because a lot of times the people that
are complaining about us quote unquote
sexualizing attractive female actresses
in their 20s will then turn around and
say that it's empowering to be a quote
unquote sex worker so it's very confused
on their
end but I think often what
happens and seems to be happening here
is that especially when you have these
older actresses that are that are using
the term
um when they say that they were being
sexualized all it really means is that
people noticed that an adult woman is
attractive and that is not sexualizing
and that is also not objectifying it's
you're not turning someone into an
object like if Jennifer Love hu was in a
in a movie when she was 25 people
watched it and said well she's she's an
attractive woman it's not sexualizing
it's not no one is denying your Humanity
they're just simply noticing that
fact
um and now it's it's it's kind of
retroactively going back and saying this
is a terrible thing and you should feel
guilty for it it's all while at the same
time
again praising sex workers it's all it's
just a whole jumbled mess of confusion
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there